how's it going everyone it's Warren and
Captain Marvel definitely gave us some
surprises specifically in regards to the
kree-skrull war and then at the end of
the movie when all is said and done we
see Captain Marvel leave earth and shoot
into space but we know that she's going
to return to earth for Avengers in game
so the question is where has she been
this whole time and what has she been
doing well Marvel Studios as President
Kevin Feige has recently talked about
this in a recent interview about
Avengers endgame I'll talk about what he
said and break it all down in this video
but first if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe I'm doing a new
giveaway giving away five imax tickets
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so before I talk about what
Kevin Feige had to say about this I have
to issue a spoiler alert if you have not
seen Captain Marvel there are some
spoilers coming so like I mentioned in a
recent interview about Avengers in game
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige was
asked about what happened to Carol
Danvers for the many years she was going
through outer space alongside the scroll
here's what he had to say will we see it
lived through more yeah I mean I think
one of the things that's fun to us about
the timeline of this film and the
potential of future stories with these
characters is there's a great past not
just of Marvel but of the entire scroll
Creek conflict and also this gap of
history between when Carol Danvers flew
off with Talos at the end spoiler and
when she arrives with the Avengers so
for those of you who think that the
kree-skrull war was done injustice in
the movie and that it's already over
don't worry it's not but Kevin Feige
goes on to say we wanted to give her her
own corner of the universe her own
mythology
while we're not specific about this in
the movie there's potential to
understand where has she been this whole
time why haven't we seen her yet the
answer is revealed and hinted at in this
movie endgame as she was dealing with a
colossal universal conflict in another
section of the MCU those are some really
intense words their colossal Universal
conflict basically a war a colossal war
we also learned this from the footage
that was shown to the shareholders at
Disney's annual shareholders meeting in
the scene that was shown Carol is
talking to the rest of the Avengers and
wrote
asked where she's been this whole entire
time in which she tells him she was
fighting for other planets who don't
have heroes like the Avengers to protect
them so this combined with what Kevin
Feige says it is clear that she was
fighting some huge war in space but now
the question is who was she fighting and
could this person be the second threat
in Avengers endgame could this threat
have followed her back to earth and
since she's been fighting wars in space
since 1995 she probably has ran into and
has fought Ronan again
and since Ronan was hired by Thanos to
collect a Power Stone how she already
Reina to Thanos before in the MCU
perhaps this would explain why in the
footage that was shown to the
shareholders Captain Marvel tells the
other Avengers that they have to go and
find and fight Thanos now she most
likely knows who he is since she's been
fighting a universal conflict in space
perhaps she's fought him before and
that's why she's saying they need to go
fight him now of course if she has
fought him before it was before he got
the Infinity stones so if she goes and
fights him now she's in for a very rude
awakening but let me know what you think
about this Kevin Feige himself says that
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel was
fighting a colossal universal conflict
in space in another section of the MCU
that's what she's been doing this whole
time but has she fought Thanos before
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching Wolf
Wolf
[Music]
[Music]